classé le directeur des relations
humaines le dr je connais des questions
puisqu'on a satine et aïssa est ce qu'on
peut grande première question non pas du
tout cette agression a trébuché le drh
dit nous sommes une émission il ya
satine bonsoir bonsoir
quel est ton émission préférée mon
émission préférée
ouais c'est tpn p merci ça tient ou ça
même question y at il quelqu'un qui
t'accompagne quand tu regardes ton
émission préférée
oui c'est mon chien bon allez on sait
qu'être médecine qui est l'animateur tv
que tu préfères toi non mais dis la
vérité
ben je sais pas je ne connais pas encore
très bien d'accord
sa question je te poser vos questions à
thé déjà eu une aventure avec un
animateur télé non tadic et là il aura
que d'une chose c'est se marier une
cinquième fois satine quel est ton
chroniqueurs préférés
autour de cette table oui hélas parce
qu'elle s'endort à nador et ouais c'est
vrai mais ça c'est beau c'est la belle
au bois dormant mais bien dormi non pas
la règle de vie est magnifique
il s'appelle vous avez un succès tout
même yann m'a dit qui en fait qui va
peut-être changer la vie à bord par la
chaîne gilles manor méchoui
bon bah vous savez quoi c'est bon vous
êtes prise tout et de nos oreilles ça ça
va vous êtes contents d'être là grave
vous connaissez des gens liés ou pas du
tout merci beaucoup oui oui oui
connaissent et qui jean pascal vous je
suis désolé votre et non je vous ai vu
la sncb mardi mais je me rappelle chez
nadine morano et puis voilà bon bah elle
et les nouvelles du coup il a belle vous
faisiez jeu vidéo gag mais bernard
montiel le prénom je suis désolé je
remercie guillaume c'était quand même
une demi heure qu'elle discute avec ma
mère
mais bah c'est sympa pour le m si l'on
fait mais il m'a pas donné son prénom
by iphone on a tout fait mais dernière
qui vous a pas fait une couleur de jeu
c'est pas de la force